كشفت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وفشلها حتى
الان في اخضاعها ضعف الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين وانهض صوته على جيرانه الاصغر خصوصا
دول اسيا الوسطى التي لا طالما اعتبرتها
موسكو جزء من ارث الاتحاد السوفيتي لعل
ابرز مؤشرات تراجع الصوت والروسيه تكونت
في موقف كازاخستان
وطاجكستان اللاتيني عارض عارضته علنا
الغزو الروسي اوكرانيا
الوثيق بموسكو التي دعمت السلطه في
كازاخستان قبل اشهر ضد انتفاضه شعبيه
هدفها اسقاط النظام التحول في كازاخستان
هو الاهم فالقوه النفطيه المتراميه
الاطراف عمك علاقاتها مع الصين وتركيا
واوربا وجذبت مئات الشركات الغربيه التي
خرجت من روسيا كما سمحت للالاف من الروس
بالهرب من التجنيد عسكري بالعبور منها كما
تقول هنا الواشنطن بوست رئيس كازاخستان
قاسم جمعه الذي التقى بالرئيس الفرنسي في
باريس لمناقشه عميق العلاقات الاقتصاديه
في رساله واضحه لموسكو عن بحث كازاخستان
عن بديل رحله الرئيس هنا جاءت عقب
اجتماعات الرئيس اوزباكستاني شوكت همم
ميروسيوف مع ماكرون في باريس الاسبوع
الماضي ارمينيا هي الاخرى بدات الخروج من
العباءه الروسيه حيث اعرضت عن غضبها من
نقص الدعم في الصراع العسكريه المستمر مع
اذربيجان
[موسيقى]